each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
today I'm going to to present a very
high level view of the kind of work we
do and the kind of vision that is behind
the work we do in privacy technology now
I was told that and I have seen the
previous tutorials we have here in the
lab that we try to keep them accessible
to everybody around and for this reason
privacy is actually a particularly easy
subject to tackle because we all have
feelings about it it is something that
most people would feel strongly one way
or the other about other people will
come down on the side that yeah privacy
doesn't really matter and they will
argue very vigorously about it or they
will come down on the side that privacy
really matters and they will argue very
vigorously about that point so I'm going
to talk a little bit about perceptions
of privacy and how they have evolved
over the last ten years let's say in the
media but also how the reality of
surveillance has evolved in the last ten
years at least from what we know from
the media and from other research but
then I will dive a little bit down
beyond hearsay and the news etc into
some important foundational questions of
what we do first of all I would like to
give a slightly more scientific take on
the obvious question that everybody has
in their mind do people really care
about privacy okay because that's really
the starting point for doing privacy
anything like is there such a thing as
privacy and in what way do people care
or not the etc etc the second concrete
thing of like to talk about which will
support my role here as a kind of
privacy champion is what frameworks do
we have that are established to think
about privacy like before you start
making products or putting services out
to the public you know what things
should you think about that really if
you go and talk to a very established
lawyer a politician they will tell you
that's the way
should really be handling privacy but
then i would like to also move a little
bit beyond that and talk about our
vision for privacy which goes way way
beyond what is already recognized and
establish today as what we do and really
combines the the most cutting-edge
technologies in the computer security
and cryptography field to actually
facilitate processors that are mindful
of privacy and services that do not
actually violate privacy while providing
very rich functionality and I will
conclude on a few thoughts of mine about
what kind of paradigm shift we need to
see for this technologies to leave our
labs and really have a profound impact
upon the world and whether we will see
the shifts or not is something that you
can hold me accountable for and maybe a
10 20 years time at which point I will
have retired now one thing is that
despite the fact that a lot of the
research particularly the later parts
are very heavy on maths in Krypton
Staten code and other very hardcore
geekery I'm going to stay way away from
those things right now and on purpose
talk about very high-level concepts at
the same time I don't want to bore you
so the concepts are going to be actually
quite hard at time so please you know
try to follow and do ask questions if
something is a bit loose or a bit
unclear I will fully engage with you on
that note i also have references in the
presentation that you can have later to
the sources of all the maths and other
geekery and please come and talk to me
later if you want lair ification is
about any of the more technical aspects
now let's first start with the
perceptions let's first talk about how
is privacy seen and how has that changed
in the last 10 years now I've been in
the UK for maybe 15 years and really
particularly with the events at the
beginning of this century with the
terrorist attacks and in the UK of the
terrorist attacks in 2005 privacy was
not really a very huge concern outside
very small circles that somehow are
specifically concerned about it advocacy
circles etc etc but in around 2007 this
changed the
and the way changed is that the media
started increasingly reporting
government departments using data
usually in the post to be fair with you
they would as part of their normal
processes of auditing just write a DVD
send it off and the DVD would be lost in
the post and somehow that ended up in
the newspapers which before that I
wouldn't have thought was particularly
newsworthy multiple incidents like this
kept creeping up it was not just a
one-off that died off it turned out that
department after department after
department started reporting these
incidents and basically the perceptions
in the the media kind of snowballed into
thinking that this is kind of a constant
state of affairs that data is being
given to the government and then just
mishandled and lost in the most silly
way possible as well now of course the
government you know provided a rather
confused response to that not a very
technological response mostly a
political response which are not
particularly going to go into but there
is one component of it that is what
instinct was they were very rushed to
say that look we're handling this
personal data and yes sure we are losing
it that's fair game it's true we're
losing it but we are actually handling
them for an important purpose like
auditing the work of departments is very
important right so basically the
underlying assumption there was and the
message was well cut us some slack
basically you know we're trying to do
this job and we're doing it as much as
well as we can and yes sure we're losing
some data every so often but it's really
important that we do this job so you
know you have to something to put up
with these risks yeah I mean that's
really the message coming out of this so
it really gave a think a perception of
very low quality of engineering first of
all and technology and also very low
quality of processes that you know allow
this situation to occur again and again
and again and privacy as I said before
is a very emotive field and I think as
this story started appearing more and
more in the media you know different
kind of feelings appeared towards the
government handling of the situation I
mean amateurism is something that
probably will creep
in all our minds as technologists you
know people perceive this as a failure
of the duty of care that the data
handler had it also kind of strikes of
systemic in competence it's not just a
one-off thing it's just the whole thing
is not designed to handle data very well
and then on top of that this idea that
well you have to kind of put it put up
with it because we're doing something
important is kind of striking a bit of a
false choice it's like you know I give
you my data to do something sure but you
know I'm not expecting you really to
lose it because you have to do your job
so but at the same time to be fair
despite all this store is and this kind
of torrent of similar stories there is a
distinct lack of malice there like
everybody knows that the government has
to hold data usually this data is given
to the government by the individual and
there is really only a potential risk
this the CDs and DVDs were lost but
nothing really bad happened it's not
really clear that they landed in the
wrong hands and were used for identity
theft or for extortion or for whatever
other scenarios were put forward and at
the end of the day sure the government
has a point that the recent benefit in
processing data it's not totally without
any merit so um this is the storage from
2007 and of course I tried to look for a
story that is slightly more recent
because that's a bit stale and I was
lucky enough to just look at the front
page of The Guardian yesterday and as I
was preparing at the second slide
looking for the really latest thing
right and not only the top story was
about privacy but also it turns out that
the national newspaper has a whole
section on privacy which frankly
speaking ten years ago would be
unthinkable in in my view it wouldn't be
something that people would discuss so
much right and what is the story from
yesterday the iphone apparently keeps a
record of everywhere you go it has
basically a file it's actually a
database it's not just some kind of cash
or anything that records every place you
have been the longitude allowed you to
the time into a file and it just keeps
it there now it turns out that this is
actually in the terms of service this
data is not automatically given to
Apple but it is there if you basically
say yes sure I would like this service
to access my location data to provide no
right right so maybe i'm not totally up
to date with exactly all the details
maybe you have been attached to your
newsfeed more as i was writing this
presentation so but as i understand it
right right it is in the Terms of
Service like in the face of it it's
pretty much legit it's just something
that was there that users did not expect
okay this is really the extent of this
story it is just something that the
average user who was going around with
their phone wouldn't really expect and
this is like creating a feeling of
betrayal it seems that is profound
enough to propel a story to the front
page of a national newspaper which I
find quite incredible and this leads us
back to a concept that Frank's tashana
from next door came up with in 2004 in a
paper that he called will your digital
Butler betray you the idea is that as we
live in a technologically rich world we
come to see our devices and as an
extension of our will and extension of
our agency and extension of ourselves so
when suddenly our digital devices or
services turn around to do something we
don't expect and potentially put can put
us at risk or potentially isn't
something that we want we feel betrayed
okay and that creates a negative feeling
towards the services in particular he he
flagged the very real risk he said that
there is really nothing in our cultural
perception of right and wrong much less
in law to protect your digital Butler
this phone with all the location data
from this information being techno
tortured out of them if someone
basically takes this phone and you know
just plugs it into a computer and read
the file it's not anything wrong right I
mean it's not like you know going to
someone cursing them to betray someone
else's trust it's just one of these
things that would happen okay and you
would think that this is again just a
potential risk in a potential store and
very much
the story broke out yesterday and there
is no specific negative event that has
happened as a result but at this very
same time actually three days ago there
was a this article on slashdot that
talked about how the state police in
Michigan has actually a device and they
usually device every time they stop
people from minor traffic offenses to
actually suck the data out of the mobile
phones it's not quite clear how much
they they take out as a matter of
routine it's not quite clear if they're
using it to the full potential isn't
quite clear what their legality or
illegality of this is but this is a
state of play so we suddenly see that
these perceptions of betrayal and ill
feeling that are quite abstract as time
progresses take more and more concrete
forms a very concrete risks that people
may perceive is a V for example the
state or other entities another example
is your laptop and border controls the
US and the UK have actually been looking
through hard disks of laptops to find
all sorts of things from pornography to
terrorism related documents and another
issue that is not anymore just about
devices is that some employers are now
starting to ask for social networking
credentials as part of your clearance
process right you know this is really
confounding two spaces one that is your
professional world and one that is more
thought as your social world now to be
fair these things are corrected quite
quickly right and the Department of
Corrections are things backed off quite
quickly when this became an issue but we
went from just a general feeling of
malaise of incompetents to a general
feeling of I'm a bit worried about
potential violations to agenda two of
potential betrayal to a feeling that oh
my god maybe violations are happening as
we speak now of course it is easy to to
say in all these cases well they are
happening within a context where the
rule of law is strong and therefore any
violations that may even happen will be
redressed very quickly as in the case of
the correctional facilities asking for
people's login details but if we
in two jurisdictions where the rule of
law is a little bit more loose
particularly last January in Tunisia
where they were I think in the middle of
a full-blown what we could call
revolution the the actual potential for
privacy violation and the the actual
reality of privacy violation that
doesn't quite make it as this kind of
torrent of information in the news is
kind of raised even more so what
happened in Tunisia which is a very
interesting for all of us who release
services the government through the
internet service provider that belongs
to the government basically ran phishing
attacks on the users of social
networking sites as well as internet
email sites I think in particular it was
Gmail Yahoo and Facebook so as the
connection would go through the National
I speed that gives connectivity to the
outside world javascript would be
injected into the page to grab the
credentials for authentication and give
them back to the government that was
then using them to log in to people's
profiles close them up open up whatever
do surveillance and this happened
basically throughout weeks and forced
all these major providers to start using
stronger privacy technologies that have
been available to some extent for the
last 15 years in the form of SSL to do
authentication but also to protect the
whole session and to make sure that
you're talking to the right party so of
course all these services were developed
by people who are well-meaning that did
what is seemingly a rational decision
and to say that our government would
never mount such attacks but of course
when they thought of their government
most of them thought of the United
States and to some extent they are right
that their government might not be
mounting those attacks but they didn't
quite think that their customer base is
not just under that government that is
actually a global customer gave customer
base including in places where the rule
of law is not in the same place as what
they expected in the United States or
wherever they were developing this now
even if we look at the the reality in
places where the rule of law is stronger
such as our countries the UK the United
States the last ten years particularly
because of the the terrorist attacks in
2001 have not been totally flawless when
it comes to protection of privacy and
actually the promotion of surveillance
capabilities in the infrastructure
starting in 2001 but also throughout the
the noughties the United States actually
engaged in mass surveillance it turns
out mass surveillance of internet
traffic going basically through its
major hubs where traffic comes in and
out of the country this is a serious
fraction of the traffic globally that
actually transits through America how
did they do that it is actually a
fascinating technological achievement
because these are gigabit and gigabit
networks and that that basically were
observed in real-time they put optical
splitters in the big facilities that
where the big transatlantic cables land
and they constructed a whole shadow room
inside the facilities of the telecom
providers in particular AT&T who are
these cables of these basically split
fiber optic cables were arriving where
they put stacks and stacks and stacks of
deep packet inspection equipment that
was doing traffic selection and
forwarding the selected traffic back to
the NSA as far as the people who
investigated the situation can tell now
this was done in real time the packet
the deep packet inspection boxes were no
responses that could be reprogrammed to
actually look for particular patterns
and forward them on the interception was
done without a warrant under particular
exemptions at for national security that
we're used in a blanket fashion and I
have to say that if we're looking for
one of the marvels of the 21st century
along with our data centers that would
put that as one of the things that
should be compared with the pyramids
it's an amazing achievement of
Technology there is a lot of data we
never thought before actually this was
documented that you could do
interception at such an amazingly large
scale basically every packet coming in
and out of the country being filtered
and selected or not selected and then
those selected forward it
that's right that's right so but what is
true is that every jurisdiction in the
world has some provisions for lawful
access and as I said this is not
automatically unlawful of course lawyers
are battling this spill in court whether
it was lawful or not but you could
actually make a law that makes this
perfectly fine the Tunisian government
probably had a law that made what they
did perfectly fine and you know no one
has gone to jail for any of this in the
United States either and there are there
are provisions for lawful access to
communications there are legal
frameworks around them there are
technical standards by which routers are
built to support that so that you know
you don't have you have interoperability
between surveillance equipment these are
integrated into the infrastructure of
every ISP that has to have a license and
there is a vibrant vendor ecosystem
around basically the intelligence
community that provides tools for
interception and analysis of data and
this is actually ticking at the rate
that the IT industry is ticking there is
a lot of innovation there are a lot of
clever people working on this thing and
there is all this is designed both for
targeted surveillance usually if it is
for police work or it can be actually
turned for mass surveillance as it was
the case here there is a fascinating
book called the shadow factory that
actually documents all this in in
intimate detail and I do recommend it I
have a copy in my office if you would
like to read all about how the the
technical details of this worked as far
as we we can tell now another aspect of
modern life and technology is of course
financial transactions financial
transactions you can are all electronic
these days you cannot really buy a car
with cash anymore and again I'm not
going to labor this issue but over 2006
Swift which is doing all the intra
banking transactions mirrored its copy
of the database to the United States at
the Department of Treasury and the CIA
for doing data mining related to
terrorism it was condemned by the
Belgian and the German government but
such as life
so again how should people feel about
this technical infrastructure that is
now used to basically do or money things
right but of course it seems that i'm
picking on on the united states when it
comes to the potential for mass
surveillance and i don't want to give
this impression because in the european
union as well which is otherwise quite
mindful of privacy as a as a as a right
i guess there have always been
innovation in law to give law
enforcement access to what is called
traffic data namely not the content of
your communication on the content of
your email or the voice in a Nicole but
actually who is talking to whom for how
long where they are all the data
associated with communications the fear
of law enforcement in the unit in the EU
was that because of the strong privacy
protections service providers offering
communications would actually start
deleting this data because they are
obliged to in theory and therefore that
might impede their investigations into
serious crimes and other crimes and
therefore a regime was needed to ask
them specifically to keep some data
items to facilitate the investigations
if they're only opened a few months
after a crime has been committed okay so
by 2006 at the UK government and you
know the date is not coincidental it's
very close after the terrorist attacks
in the UK passed well facilitated an EU
directive that basically mandated the
mandatory traffic data retention
throughout Europe and that basically
says that Internet service providers and
telecommunication providers should
retain all this traffic data for from
six months to two years depending on how
the directive is implemented in each
country okay now what is this data it's
you know traffic data how much does
traffic data say about you caspar bowden
who today is actually working for
microsoft as our privacy officer called
it closes circuit television from inside
your head it's basically your click
stream as you as you move around as you
click on the web as you basically look
at pages it records what you do
but lately one of the German members of
parliament I believe actually wanted to
really visualize what is this data
looking like what is this traffic data
so what he did is he entered into a
prolonged a legal battle with their
telecommunication provider their mobile
provider to actually get all that data
for six months I believe and then handed
it over to a newspaper that pre that
presented a very nice visualization of
what this data really looks like that is
being retained by default even after it
is needed allow me to play just a very
small fraction of it you can see that
you have a few days to choose from the
life of that person will just start
roughly at twelve o'clock on the twenty
first of august 2009 and see what you
can really find out about that person so
as you can see they're kind of taking
the train the trains are nice and fast
in Germany they every time they are
within a cell of a mobile phone location
that cell basically triangle is their
position every time they're making a
call you can see a little phone that
says who they have cold you can see
where they have been you can see where
they sleep you can see quite who
basically they meet if you see a two of
these phones it is pretty granular where
when the directive was passed of course
we only had 2g technology so the cells
were rather large and it was a bit you
know very fine not so very fine-grained
these days because we will use 3G phones
the actual information that is available
about every single one of us that has a
phone that is stored for a year or so is
pretty granular and it actually moves so
fast that Google Maps can't really
handle it sometimes so we're talking
here and this is why I have shifted term
perceptions where there is a big scandal
because somehow your iPhone stores a
file of locations to the reality of it
which is actually quite grave because
not only your iPhone stores that data
but it is actually available to your
service provider in real time whether it
is recorded on the phone or not and
whether whether you have consented or
not and it is actually
pain for about two years I think in the
UK or a year and a half if Robert Hayes
was here he would be able to tell us so
this is roughly what the visualization
looks like you can you can have a lot of
fun finding out where his home is I
think that this is a nice exercise for
all of us later on today so the problem
is not only that your government can
access this data this is a classic
problem and to some extent is a
constitutional law problem how do you
avoid abuses it is not just that another
government may access your data that
this is not actually subject anymore to
to protection from from your part
because you're not a citizen of the
United States to actually have any
constitutional guarantees of privacy but
it is also the case that once you build
in a surveillance infrastructure into
the infrastructure then it might
actually be abused by random third
parties as well and this is indeed what
happened in Greece again in 2006 2006
was a very good year when it comes to
your privacy scandals a lot of things
happen in 2006 when it was discovered
that through using and abusing and
bypassing the access controls of the
lawful interface interception
capabilities in the Greek
telecommunication provider Vodafone the
Greek branch of Vodafone unknown party
still today had managed to get access to
the traffic data and the cold data of a
hundred members of basically the ruling
elite in Greece beat the prime minister
which is quite a good catch really if
you're going to do surveillance on
anyone the head of staff of the army the
police the Navy G journalists Arab
businessman a whole I think the head of
the opposition as well was included was
not particularly party partisan as a
surveillance goes and that had very
severe repercussions on Vodafone the the
provider severe at the tune of about 51
million pounds of the time fine because
they didn't take care of their security
but at the end of the day no one knows
who did it no one knows why they did it
and no one knows I you know if you know
this is still going on
some different manner but what is known
is that the mechanism by which this was
achieved was by simply by passing the
access controls in the infrastructure
that was already built to do
surveillance and once basically people
have the codes to get in they just
configured the system to just listen in
to the calls so I talked a lot about
government related surveillance and you
know both the perceptions of people have
of you know the problems that
governments have in dealing with
personal information but also the kind
of potential for mass surveillance that
we're building into our infrastructure
for for very good reasons but that has
the potential to be abused in more than
than one ways these days lots of people
talk about the data that is available in
private hands the data that is in our
data centers in Google's hands in
Facebook's hand etc etc etc and I didn't
bother actually going through the
stories because there are so many answer
reason that many of you have seen them
it suffice to say that lots of stories
appear about the potential of price
discrimination if I know how much you're
ready to pay for a book i'll just charge
you that instead of giving you the best
deal there is a potential for employment
problems insurance problem
creditworthiness particularly in the
United States but of course there is
also the interaction between private
entities and we have seen the examples
of Vodafone the examples of Apple and
how they deal with the latest story with
government access and sadly there is a
rather unsophisticated message being
given from the very top the leadership
which should be a technical leadership
of very large technical companies about
this situation this is actually a
statement by Eric Schmidt where the time
was a google CEO saying that basically
if you are doing something that you
don't want others to find out maybe you
shouldn't be doing it that's the first
kind of opening salvo of his of his
quote and then he says well you know you
should assume that any information we
have basically the government could have
and by the government they actually mean
the US government again they don't go as
far as thinking the Chinese government
who later that year actually did ask
them for some data and they decided as a
result to basically fold their
operations in china why is that because
these are
in their system under that assumption
that it's okay to give to have all this
data and well it's a fact of life that
you know when we're asked for it in
whichever jurisdiction in turned up
which I don't think is what they were
thinking at the time they were designing
the systems we will have to give them a
tour so one interesting thing to think
about is how should the Greek Prime
Minister feel about that statement like
it should just be stopping doing what
he's doing like external policy and you
know setting that the government's
policies with the amount of
confidentiality this requires is he
doing something wrong and this is why he
needs confidentiality I don't think so
but of course the Greek Prime Minister
is a bit of an extreme example I think
that everybody who is engaged in
negotiations either at a personal level
or at a professional level is business
and all that stuff has at some point the
need to think for themselves or look for
information and communicate with others
without being subject of surveillance in
an arbitrary fashion so what about the
CEO of Airbus do they feel comfortable
in this particular case the US
government because we're talking again
about Google to have access to their
traffic data or other data or search
data when they're a direct competitor of
Boeing and how of course is this
attitude and this message that we have
been giving as an industry from the very
top now interfering with our ability to
sell things like the cloud when we tell
people trust us because we will store
your data and everything is going to be
fine and then our customers just spend
some time in a search engine and find
these statements that basically don't
play very well with this messaging that
now we're trying to give away
well ah that is a very good question so
let's indeed indeed so in the next to
slide in the next to slide I will start
discussing exactly that what about
paying a little bit more for privacy
could could we solve the problem like
this and I have some data and then maybe
you can ask exactly the same question
after that so that it's motivated by
what we have seen so what we have seen
so far is a bit of hearsay you know
journalists are journalists they they
try to find what's exciting they tried
to second guess what's exciting but what
has been exciting to them is more and
more privacy than though actually what
they're digging out to put on the front
pages is not even the tip of the iceberg
of the amount of surveillance that
actually happens in the infrastructure
and it's not clear to me why exactly
they are so excited about the Apple
story rather than for example the story
that we saw before where all the traffic
data is retained even not just on your
iPhone but anywhere else so the the
perceptions are a bit bad the reality is
also pretty bad and the question is now
do people care and I think this comes
down to some extent assignments question
because do people care it has many
components to it first of all our people
feeling emotionally involved in this
issue of privacy & Technology okay and
we've talked already about this feeling
of betrayal that is really key I think
in our relationship with anything but
what is more important for us as a
technology company is would people pay
for it okay would people care enough
that if Microsoft spent 1,000,000
developing a privacy friendly version of
search or of the iphone would people as
a collective body of customers pay 1
million or more to actually buy that and
would we compete on that basis with the
iphone right because if people care
enough to prefer a privacy friendly
option or to switch to a privacy
friendly option that's good news for us
because we have great researchers in
privacy and we can compete like that
yeah so do they care but most
importantly even before getting there we
must sell
reflect a bit about how do we find out
how do we know if someone cares are not
about privacy and yes so a mars bar this
is the story that appeared a few years
back in 2004 and it says that the
husband a study where people were
offered a mars bar in exchange of their
password again this has really become
fact this is this is the most extreme so
i have a few mars bars if anyone would
like to come to me after like no one
will know you know just it's very nice
it's very sweet if they say over seventy
percent of response are willing to
divulge their passwords for nothing more
than so this is the hearsay this is not
particularly scientific and it very much
mirrors though the top of the leadership
now of sun that said well you have zero
privacy anyway just get over it blah
blah blah but this is not what we're
interested in we're interested in a
slightly more scientific way of looking
at the problem so people from academia
have looked at this problem do people
care about privacy and some people are
actually quite negative about it Felix
toddler said well privacy is a thing of
modernity 17th century modernity when
there was the writing word that
dominated the world and then you could
write something and separate it from
yourself and then you have privacy
because you didn't have to associate
yourself with this writing anymore but
these days it's all about interactive
media and chat and all that stuff and
updating your facebook status it's not
very easy to separate yourself anymore
from your persona that you give outside
through the medium of writing therefore
forget about privacy it's a thing of the
past it's not in our ebook anymore and
people will just accept that eventually
but the truth is that he wrote that in
2002 and people haven't really got over
it because we had a guardian article
again on the front page yesterday about
it so there is some issue there and I
think one of those credible known
quantitative studies about people's
perception of privacy in the use of
services such as Facebook is actually by
a Microsoft researcher than a Boyd who
looked at how teenagers who are very
often stigmatized that not being very
privacy conscious actually use online
services and what is their relationship
to these online services and privacy and
she has a whole PhD
this is worse love this I'll just take
one highlight she basically says that
teenagers were stopped and prevented
from going out in the street because of
this craze that the streets are not
particularly safe and therefore you know
ended up on the internet in my space
because this was the only place they
could actually meet each other okay many
of them said we would rather have met
our friends in the street but you know
our parents say you have to be back
early and you know you can't go out and
supervise in the park as you know in the
past and then she says that basically to
the teenagers myspace was a more privacy
friendly space where they had more
control rather than their home that was
very much a situation where their
parents had very much control or their
schools where their school teachers has
controlling etc etc so funnily enough
teenagers when they started populating
the social networks so it has the place
they could have privacy visa V the
people they cared about not the
government not Google not myspace but
their mom right and this created this
perverse situation where people would
pour out their hearts because they knew
that their parents wouldn't see this by
the fact that everybody else could see
it right and I mean you know teenagers
kissing in the straighten on the you
know in the park is not something that
we're unfamiliar with so it kind of
makes sense because they have nowhere
else to go right so but we wanted to
have slightly more quantitative ways of
finding out how much privacy is worth so
we kind of made a few studies first of
all you can't just ask people how much
is privacy worth for you because they'll
get all self-important and so your
privacy is very important for me I would
not give it out for anything but then we
see that for a mars bar to just take
this study that is not particularly
trustworthy they might actually give
away their paso so how do we know that
what they say corresponds to what what
they do so we started back in 2004 a
very celebrated series of studies that
deceives the users we pretend to the
users that we're doing something else to
just confuse them a little bit and then
as a side effect of that we observe
their behavior to find out and infer how
much they value privacy in particular
what they did we did here is we said to
the users look we're looking for
volunteers for a study we're going to
pay you a little bit for that study that
will basically requires your mobile
phone traffic data for a month or a year
etc etc by the way you know which
work are you in you know are you using
your phone are you traveling out of
Cambridge how much money would you want
to participate in the study etc etc etc
we forgot about all of the questions
except the one that says how much money
do you want to participate in the study
ok because we pretended that this was
not really the point we but in fact we
were running an auction to find out what
their preferences are when it comes to
the privacy valuations and we find out a
number it's 10 pounds for non-commercial
purposes that's back in 2004 10 pounds
were worth more than today but not so
much more for commercial purposes it's a
bit more okay it's about 20 pounds or
something like that so there is a bit of
a difference it's not huge and you can
see that the variances is quite huge I
mean there are lots of people said 0 a
lot of people said much less and some
people said a bit more particularly for
the commercial but you know there is a
there is a price and you know we were
quite happy with his results we actually
validated this much more widely we did
it throughout Europe the results in
euros are comparable again for
commercial and non-commercial comparable
and one funny thing is that the Greek
population was insane they were asking
for a lot of money to give us a month of
data look at that you know everybody is
like less than 100 years like definitely
less than 100 years for the median the
Greeks we can't even see the median the
median Greek user asks for more than a
thousand euros for a month of traffic
data and that is crazy yeah because
they're all going around with a mobile
phones giving all that data away to
their service providers we said we are
University in Greece we were actually
working with partners at the University
increase we didn't lie about that yeah
oh no no no we we we said it was no no
if I did that as part of Microsoft they
will ask him for a million of course yes
yes I understand what you're saying so
and check out the dates basically this
study was done in 2006 which if you
remember was exactly a few months after
the intersection scandal in Greece so we
happen to ask people how would you feel
about giving your data when they had
been reading every single day about what
this data means how people were under
surveillance whatever precautions
has okay so that we're totally primed to
say I will never give my data okay a
thousand thousand euros there is another
little subtle paradox or inside here
that basically one month of data versus
12 months of data is not a linear
relationship 12 months of data is not 12
x 1 month and we wondered is that people
being a bit irrational about their
privacy or that is there some other
explanation okay why is it that they
undervalue a year or overvalue a month
and why is it that it's not a linear
relationship welcome back to that so
alessandra Christie took a lot of this
research and continued looking at this
problem and first of all found out that
there are weird effects when you ask
people by their privacy even if you do
it in a sly manner even if you lie to
people it's pretty difficult to do well
so he devised this experiment he said
let's give a subject a set of subject
either a ten-dollar anonymous voucher
for books let's say or a $12 traceable
voucher this was as a payment for
another decoy experiment they did some
experiment that made people press
buttons like monkeys they didn't really
care at all what they did they only care
about the payment at the end yeah okay
and then you ask them at the end whether
they would switch okay now in theory
this is equivalent to just asking people
which one would you rather pick would
you pick the 10 one that is anonymous or
the 12 one that is actually traceable a
classical economic rational behavior
would say these two should be equivalent
but what they found is that this was not
the case if you give basically someone
the anonymous card they keep it with
probability fifty two percent but if you
give them the non-anonymous card first
they would only switch it ten percent of
the time okay so basically you kind of
like accepting what you got and you get
a little bit you know you're like yeah
whatever you know no I don't want to
switch i'll just keep that it's fine
enough you appreciate more what you have
and you feel you know that giving it
away cost you more than you know taking
it on whatever okay so basically when
you ask users what do you want it really
makes a difference
you know how you have primed them and
how you have framed the problem if you
have framed this is how it is would you
like to change it vs why would you like
or what you have put first and second
actually will make a huge difference
it's not just a tiny little difference
that is just about statistically
significant an enormous difference in
their answer and as a result if you just
rely on reveal preferences of users to
find out what they think you're kind of
lost because they're not they're just
going to tell you whatever they get from
the context they're not really going to
tell you something that is a very
interesting and there is a vicious
circle if they're used to the fact that
you know this is how it is and you know
this is what the technology provides
they are likely to just stick with it
and you know not tick the box or tick
the box or whatever he also found
another paradox if somebody said would
you like to have you on short talk or
not yes that's a pretty consistent what
you said we'd like to switch over yes
you're right it's two dollars right it's
two dollars could care less yeah that is
a that is a good point
yeah so there is another paradox that he
also looked at which is the paradox of
control if you tell users you are free
to answer those embarrassing questions
and we're going to share them with other
people they go off and you know choose
which questions to answer if you tell
users a second condition which is you're
free to choose which questions to ask to
answer if you tick the box on the next
page on the same page as the questions
we will share them with other people
okay the two statements are exactly the
same they come down to do you choose at
the end of the day to give us some
answers too embarrassing questions and
are sharing them further and you observe
how many people say yes sir I will give
you a response and I will allow you to
actually share it with others and
publicize it if you have given them the
illusion of more control namely through
a check box more people not only respond
but also accept to share further okay
which is exactly the same logical
equivalent condition okay so the more
people feel that oh yeah I could have
said no therefore i will just you know
say answer and also allow people to
share the more they will open their
hearts to you okay good so to users care
the answer is from our studies and the
follow-up study this is probably this
year they put some monetary value on
things we have observed it was not zero
but it is a tricky issue and it is open
as a research problem they say one thing
they do another the value privacy and
consistently their learned in turns full
sense of safety by control tricks
basically and there are other studies
that show that the discount potential
bad things that have happened way in the
past or in the future differently from
good things that could happen in the
future even if they're actually
monetarily equal so there is a key
challenge from us engineers which is
that asking users their opinion on
privacy is not really a safe way of
refining requirements about what privacy
controls and protections are technology
should have so do some extent there is a
little bit of a second guessing and a
little bit of a
deeper qualitative analysis that has to
go into what exactly is the technology
that we're going to be building looking
like yes safeway why it was you asking
do you want your hair to be yeah only
wouldn't say with the most I understand
yes yes yes see boy to this than the day
to his tally the data is pretty shocking
actually the ten percent fifty percent
like you know what if asked you would
you prefer to have a Haskell compiler or
C++ compiler you know you have an answer
to that and you know people would have
an answer to that and then I change the
question too would you rather have a C++
come you know I give half the people c++
compiler in the other half a Haskell
compiler and ask them to switch and then
at random and the two groups come up
with totally different answers from when
asked to start with like you're right
that the effect is very small like the
two dollars is very small but then you
expect people to just go randomly as
well and on the second condition right
yeah maybe they're like okay I'm done
and I'm taking my voucher and go so
that's that's a good way of refining the
things now the key problem is that our
industry is increasingly relying on this
kind of like self-reporting asked a
hundred users and collate the the
results first of all I mean the priming
starts you know with using a model I
guess instead of me on the on the cover
of these certainties research but they
just basically go around for GC did this
study about personal data in the cloud
and they say would you feel that using
personal data for traffic management is
you know k or for other things that
basically the answers you get out of
that our random i spend like about a day
thinking why are people thinking base
like everybody goes to amazon and does
personalized shopping every time you
register your giving some
recommendations everybody likes it why
do they say that the dangers outweigh
the benefits like this is a day to day
occurrence in comparison with traffic
management which involves basically
someone knowing your location of your
car all the time the people quite
freaked out about why do people say that
it's basically not that are that much of
a problem and it all
depends if you read the fine print about
how people were asked and then you may
make some theories about why the results
basically make no sense with other
studies and all the time conflicting and
contradictory they also say all say that
they want you know control more control
which is going with all this now so the
question then is ok so if we assume that
now methodologically users care a little
bit about privacy and now as a
methodological assumption i will say
users care a little bit about privacy
how do we go about protecting privacy
now we'll go quite fast about this there
are three key ways in which basically we
can protect privacy that are interesting
to us as researchers and we will look at
I will mostly focus on this one because
it's the one you will have to take care
of the first one is industry
self-regulation this works well when
industry is and technology is very
fast-moving but fundamentally you know
that's that after a while you start
needing a bit more regulation around in
the US one thing that was very popular
and it still is a data breach disclosure
and the second one in the EU is data
protection so in the US they basically
are using the power of embarrassment to
do basically what Simon was suggesting
to let the market take care of privacy
if you hold private data and you lose it
or you get hacked a bit like the UK
government did a while ago then you have
to tell your customers and the idea is
that the customers this way will respond
to the signal through the market and
choose the providers and punish the
providers that did that and shoot the
providers that safe keep their data now
the problem with that is that it kind of
rewards the wrong incentives if you're
really lousy and you never even detect
the breeches like all your computers are
malware ridden etc etc etc then you will
never actually find any breaches you
will never report those breaches you're
going to be very upstanding privacy
citizen that's not very good but they're
trying to find ways around that as well
in the EU we have opted for a setting of
data protection where you basically have
a data subject and a data controller
that holds the data and the data
controller asks questions this comes
from the 80s where the governor was
asking you questions in your senses what
would you like to buy and you say I
would like
pride and prejudice and now this
information is really about you and that
is personal data if you say something
slightly more controversial like the
communist manifesto or the wealth of
nations that might give indications
about your political leanings that is
sensitive personal data because there
are some categories of data that are
more sensitive than others but the
important thing about this whole
framework is that again the EU was
worried that people will be reluctant to
share data across countries so the data
has to be shared but it has to be
regulated so that no crazy stuff happens
and people stop sharing data okay and
the idea is here that the data has to be
processed according to some rules and
there are eight of these rules you have
to ask for the consent of the subject
you have to have very specific purpose
you have to ask for the minimum amount
of data actually for just the right
amount of data for what you want to do
for that purpose it has to be correct
you have to delete it when you don't
need it anymore you have to give the
subject of the right to access the data
you have about them you have to keep it
securely and you cannot give it to your
friend who's not going to abide by those
rules they all ask when you transfer the
data everybody has to abide by those
rules as I said before this is all about
facilitating the transfer of data and
these are the rules that we must abide
by when we release services really and
you know this is the mental checklist
that I will take through you now there
is a small exam which we will not take
because Andrew tells me that there is
too much I've overrun my time which is
that there are confusing details what
about IP address is it personal data or
not is it sensitive what about lightly
anonymized data is that anonymized
enough you know what if someone else in
your organization has an index that
candy anonymize them what if someone
else in the world has an index that can
be anonymised them is that sufficient is
that still personal data can I actually
store your data on a cloud provider I
store your data on a third-party cloud
provider who's the data controller me
the other cloud provider what if it is
encrypted under my key does that make a
difference if I encrypt the data and
then store it on Facebook what if it is
in Krypton to do your key does that make
a difference the legislation is totally
unclear and finally a kind of
benenden essay which is how can you get
meaningful consent when the only
experience the user has about your
services through this opaque privacy
policy and they have no experience about
what happens in your service and the
potential inference is that one can draw
from the data okay because in the old
days they would say what is your age you
would answer your age that's very
different from looking at the movies you
are watching and then inferring
something about your age most users are
not comprehending that you can do that
so how could you have meaningful consent
so there are also other problems
relating to the strength of mechanisms
so just to make a very long story short
what and to conclude actually because I
want to allow everybody to have little
nibbles I think our vision is that we
you should move away from this mess we
should move away from building
infrastructures that allow for
surveillance in our systems we should
move away from you know this very
legalistic way of just having checkboxes
and privacy policies and just satisfy
ourselves with that we should instead
build technologies that embed quite
deeply privacy along with the rest of
the functionality into them of course we
need to sort out the need for people to
run their algorithms when they they have
online services we also need to stop any
abuse that currently we're using
identity information and personal
information or stop and we have a set of
megan's to do that which I will skip and
keep for another time because I don't
want to steal too much at time but our
vision is that we can do basically
everything else we could do before
without actually using personal data to
the extent that we're using it today
either through basically hiding the
identity of people or hiding what
they're doing in the systems and we have
a whole team of people here working on
this and at the end of the day the
reason you need to choose between
functionality or security or privacy we
have basically a menu of technologies
like e cash minimum disclosure
credential certified computations
anonymous blacklisting revocation
mechanism if we have to rebook privacy
to achieve both functionality security
and privacy
and ssh is one of the oldest examples of
this and one of the most established
just do you i leave my slide my final
slide here this is basically our
research vision our research vision is
that basically you should have your
privacy agent that does not betray you
have feeds of data about you through
your employment your smart meters in
your house your home devices your
location you bank everything basically
that produces data about you all this
information is stored in a secure way in
the cloud so you can access it
everywhere etc etc it only touches your
devices in an unencrypted way your
devices perform computations that are
then used as part of the infrastructure
wherever data processed data is needed
and subject access as required by data
protection is support a technologically
by default because you can always get
access to your data you can sync and
backup and use many different devices
you are empowered by having your mobile
devices doing computations and choosing
which computations to do and which
policies to to follow and the data feeds
are available as results rather than as
raw data to anyone who needs these
results to run their business like shops
and the government and insurance and
utilities etc and yes let's hope that
your battle does not have to betray you
in the future any questions